hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from round two of the feeder
Grand Prix 2019 a lot we have requested
it already and it is a very important
tournament this year it's a bit
different than the previous year's as
this year it's a knockout system so 16
players in a knockout system here Du
Bois will play two classic four games
against onigiri then if they tie both
classical games they are indenter going
into 25-minute rapid games then if those
are tied they're going into ten minutes
rapid games and then well up until one
emerges victorious and of course it all
ends in Armageddon if everything is is
it raw so in round one we're here we
have the white pieces they drew their
game and this is now round two so I do
hope you enjoy it and as you know it's
well not only it's it's a nice
tournament because of the money and
because there's a you know a lot of
rating a lot of very strong players two
of the winners of the Fida grand prix
will of course get their seat in the
next cycle in the candidates tournament
which will be held in in 2020 so let's
check it out without further ado but we
also do have some nice photos there we
have it a nice upgraded profile photos
from nicky riga daniel do both very nice
and onigiri and we also have some photos
here here we have a nice photo of dubov
just preparing to make his move as you
can see also very nice photo of onigiri
they're not all that satisfied with the
position but that also might just be his
you know thinking face it's hard to say
and in case I will not be showing any
Alexander Grigio games from the from the
first two runs as I haven't seen all the
games yet here are a couple of photos of
the legend himself there he is such a
Grecian nope sorry there he is a very
nice close-up so let's just enjoy that
for for a few seconds and also here we
have a another one so there you have it
also just a very nice close-up of Sasha
let's just enjoy that for for a few
moments so there it is if you enjoy
photos from Nikki I will as usual put a
links to her Instagram and Twitter page
in the description below so you know if
you enjoy such nice photos from the
chest I just wrote do feel free to
follow her and follow her work so
without further adieu do
opens the width d4 will Knight to f6 we
have c4 e6 sorry about that
and Knight to f3 and of course d5 we
enter the Queens gambit declined nothing
changed all that much from when we were
covering the Capablanca saga Bishop to
g5 with D captures on c4 and now efore
and now this is one of the lines where
it is in fact okay to defend your c4
pawn with b5 and now comes a four
standard idea when black decides the
defend the c-4 point you want to attack
the flank pawn with an even further
flying pawn we have c6 defending and now
just nice to see three preparing to
capture on b5 so black advances with b4
ninth to b1 and now as the c4 point is
yet again attacked or we defend it
better up to a6 with E 5 seems like it's
winning a piece but it's not really
there's only one good move for black
here with h6 in this position has been
played many times where you can decide
either you want to capture on f6
immediately want to go back but going
back isn't considered all that great if
you go back then g5 and okay then you
can capture and black khafre's here and
even though you've messed up black
sponsor the pawn structure it will be in
fact black will have the upper hand here
as there's not an easy way to develop
here if you go some like Knight here
then C 3 is possible you can mess up
White's castling privileges let's say B
captures just a bunch of character seer
King captures and now it's not all that
pleasant to play this we have the a
semi-open g4 for blacks rook and so on
but you know point being it's better to
capture immediately in this line Bishop
captures on f6 we have G captures and
the now comes he captures on f6 and
there are a few games in the database
where this position has been reached and
every time Queen captures on f6 was
played here we replace c5 it's a new
move in the position and it is now as of
move 11 that we have a completely new
game on our hands
Knight B to d2 of course inviting the C
to remove so Gary does it we have C 3 B
captures on c3 now you could capture on
f1 right away but the giver decides to
go for B captors and c3 instead we have
Knight to e4 now saying this isn't all
that important I'm just gonna
maybe capture played g3 maybe castle or
officially we'll see how it goes and
also the night from efore nicely defends
df6 bond so here we see capture somebody
for now creating two very deadly passed
pawns here and now you have to decide
who do you want to capture here night
capture Sun before and go for Queen d5
which now attacks the night here I would
say f3 defending now comes Bishop
captures on f1 King captures and now
Queen c4 check King here and now after
Bishop to b4 seems like a very dangerous
line and after night c2 the game
continues the white prevents black from
any immediate ideas but it's you know
it's not comfortable to play this with
the white pieces so sorry what I mean
with the white and black pieces both so
after C captures on d5 a dubov goes for
Bishop to b5 check first he says ok if
the trade happens it's gonna happen on
b5 with bobcat for Sun b-58 capture some
b5 and now
d3 seems like a very dangerous idea but
if you pick up the c3 pawn then the d3
pawn is weak and you don't really have a
good follow-up for this so after a
capture some b5 we have Queen to d5 by
giri going after this
efore night and now just Queen captures
on d4 now and now you have to decide
what you want to do here if you trade
Queens then white is just better you
don't have any developed pieces and well
white wait can just grab the c3 pawn
this point is protected you can even
save the castle you can bring down look
into the game and black still has to
decide how to go about it so here we
have Queen captures on b5 are still
keeping dubofsky in the center and also
you cannot capture with the Queen Bishop
to b4 would be deadly but you can
capture with the night and this is what
dubov does with Knight captures on c3
attacking the Queen and now Bishop to b4
just pinning this night we have
queenside castle on pinning and also
putting a rook here which is a very very
deadly piece just Queen d8 would be
checkmate
if this was allowed so you do have to
prevent it now it's possible to prevent
it with Queen to a5 or Queen to b6
aguirre one for Queen to a5 although
Queen to b6 also has some some very nice
moments to it
for example here
threatening to just you know remove the
defender of the night here Queen
captures Queen and then Bishop captures
Knight would win a piece
so after why defense that let's say
Queen King to see to now you can trade
everything Queen captures rook captures
captures captures and now you can just
start developing ninety seven you're
gonna win d f6 pawn let's say rook two
eight one just Knight captures here and
then after let's say you're okay for
you're gonna win be a seven point and
it's pretty much pretty much an even
endgame but you know it was possible to
go like like this Queen to b6 gear I
decided to go for Queen to a5
threatening to win the night here and
now comes Knight the b5 just a very nice
move with the night asking do you wanna
maybe capture my knight and then I can
deliver checkmate Queen d8 will be
checkmate get replaced Knight to a six
now the knight also enters the game The
Rock now covers the d8 square so now the
Queen can also move for a moment there
aren't all that many squares for the
Queen but there is the immediate threat
of just Queen captures night so we have
Queen captures on d7 with check King to
f8 and now again what do you do here
well you have to find the the best line
if you play something like nice the e5
which seems like you know it should be
should be enough I'm threatening
checkmate then you no longer couldn't
control the a1 square Queen to a1 check
King to see - now comes Queen to a to
check with King to c1 and now push up
the a3 check and now if you capture then
get you get Queen captures so what do
you do here queer King to see - you get
Queen to c5 check and now if you go to
the B file you get to look to be a check
and of course if you go to the D file
then just Queen captures on in five and
you're down material you're down a whole
piece and there's no way to continue
this attack black and just go King g8
King h7 bring this rook into the game
and it's all over black just wins this
so after King to f8 you have to continue
the game in the most precise way so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the best way to continue this game
for white well I have a nice sip of my
water
[Music]
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you know you just you're
just all about safety
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show kink the b1 it's a very
interesting that in a crazy position
like this there's there's room for King
b1 seems like you know wasting time but
it's really not you're preventing Queen
to a-1 there are no checks in the
position and now you are threatening a
lot of nasty ideas I mean a 95 followed
by this it would be just unpleasant so
here we have Bush up to a three Giri is
hoping for night captors on a three and
then he can get this rook into the game
with tempo Ruby eight check and now if
king c1 then you get Queen captures on a
three check King d2 and the game
continues but you know Giri has
something to firm to hold on to after
Bishop to a3 we've looked at d3 now rook
to b8 isn't all that great just rook to
b3 I will take care of any threats along
the B file so here we have Queen to b4
check and now again if you go King a 1
then Queen to b2 is checkmate so you
have to go the other way we have king -
C - and now Queen B - doesn't do all
that much for black if Queen B - check
you can escape King D 1 then you get
Queen B 1 check but there's not all that
much Queen King e2 and now there's no
good follow up if Queen checks you can
just block with the rook and of course
if you capture the rook then you can
notice that the pawn controls the e7 and
g7 square Queen d8 is just checkmate
Roka captures and rook captures and e8
is is mate
so after King 2 C 2 we have Queen - a4
check by giri king 32 and then now comes
Bishop to b4 check King to e2 and now we
have kinked g8 not allowing this King to
stay here in this very unpleasant
position he wants to play king to h7 and
then bring this rook into the game now
we have Knight to e5 threatening to
capture there on f7 deliver checkmate so
first the Queen to c2 check by Gary King
to f3 and now we have rook to f8
blocking checkmate and now again you
have to decide what to do here how nice
move seems like maybe Knight to g6 you
might think
for example if captures then okay queen
queen here is checkmate but if you play
something like this you're not
even gonna win material nor checkmate as
night the c5 is not winning for black so
again it's a very delicate position you
have to be careful now you're gonna
you're gonna lose material here you have
to let's say 97 check you're gonna move
the King you have to move the Queen
Queen d4 now Queen captures rook with
Czech you have to trade and all of a
sudden sudden you're down material and
completely losing so after look to f8
just look H to d1 bringing the last rook
into the game now with complete complete
control of the D file and now there's
not all that much black can do here as
long as this point is here in King and
Jade there's no way to bring this rook
into the game this rook not to doing all
that much Knight and a six not not
really helping out either so what do you
do here get rid tried h5 he wants to go
rook to h6 followed by rook to g6 maybe
maybe even give up some material to hurt
get rook into the game but it's it's not
even possible as you will never be able
to capture back so it's unclear what
black wants to do here but he does have
to try something and here h5 creates yet
another weakness so feel free to pause
the video here and try to find the the
absolute winning line for for Donald
above here I'll give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations you have
perfectly memorized the thumbnail and if
you look at it this is the position from
the thumbnail if you remember now Queen
d4 to a4 to g5 check out followed by
Queen g7 checkmate this is the idea so
here the world does go Queen to d4 this
is his plan so here goes
rook to h7 he creates some room for his
King on h8 but now just Queen to f4 and
again what do you do here with Bishop to
c5 there's no immediate threat well
there is but maybe Dougal doesn't find
it and now threatening Queen captures on
f2 but double goes nice to deform just
blocking the bishop here also attacking
the Queen Queen to a to getting the
Queen out of the way if the knight moves
there's still pressure against the f2
pawn but here just rook to d2 pushing
the Queen back we have Queen to d5 with
check now King retreats we have king t2
and I'll just Bishop to b4 and here
dubov delivers the final blow
we have rook sorry Knights the c6 opens
up an attack towards the Queen and also
prepares to bring this Knight over to e7
instead of this night going to c6 also
Knight f5 was also possible you're gonna
get to e7 just just the same as the
Queen is under attack and the black has
to react to that but okay Knight to d6
we have Queen to c5 getting the Queen
out of out of the rooks way and now
Knight to e7 check with King to h8 and
it was in this position that onigiri I
don't know if you resigned as he did
play King to H it or maybe his time just
ran out I believe he resigned but the
the board just remembered his last move
but it's interesting why he resigned
it's it's actually a force checkmate so
once again for the last time in this
video feel free to pause it and find
this for a nice forced checkmate again
I'll give you a couple of seconds not
even gonna have a sip of my water essage
as I already had to you know I'm you
know I'm good
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations it's a very nice
checkmate in three and for those of you
who just wanna enjoy the show
Knight captures on f7 with check I know
it's not all that exciting when a when a
puzzle you know starts with check but
you know we work with what we have and
now you can't move the King the pawn
controls discord the knife controls disk
where you can either capture it with
this rook or with this rope if this rook
captures then Queen h8 check roblox and
Queen captures on f8 is checkmate now
and on the other hand if the other rook
captures let's say this rook captures
then you get rook dat check root blocks
and then rope capture Sun f8 is once
again a checkmate on f8 so there we have
it first round a draw second round dubov
beats onigiri and eliminates onigiri
from this first part of the of the
feeder grand prix
which is which is really amazing and
everyone went crazy over it since you
know all know Donald above was one of
Magnus Carlsen seconds he calls an
announcer that only later during his
World Chess Championship match against
Fabiano Caruana
and of course you all know that Carson
always has his flame wars on twitter
with onigiri so here it was a very
exciting moment that cousins well we
could say pupil defeated
nemesis onigiri but yeah we're gonna
check out at least one more game from
either around 1 or 2 depending on on
your suggestions and you know the the
niceness of the games and then we're
gonna discuss the standings and who
eliminated who as there were were a few
you know pretty major upsets so yeah
that's basically it I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank berry
max Murdock human siren Marc gamble
Steven mills and negara Srinivasa
Vignesh for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos you're thinking for watching and
I will see you soon with some more
hopefully interesting content following
the defeat a Grand Prix if any
interesting game arises and of course
continuing the capablanca saga thank you
all I will see you soon have an
excellent rest of your Saturday